by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley and i am here to
entertain the people who have decided to
show up thank you so much once again to
everybody who's here and who decided to
click on the little thumbnail showing
amy
i am sincerely grateful once again i
know i talk about gratitude a lot on
this podcast but
there's a lot to be
grateful about and um
i'm excited to bring you another
banger of an episode if you are
experiencing this show for the very
first time because you didn't follow me
before on the haters will say youtube
page and you're following the thick boy
youtube welcome allow me to reintroduce
myself my name is mark
h-a-r to the l-e-y
i'm a pretty freaking cool and thick e
guy
okay i tried i did you know haters get
so triggered when i rap
but i have to do it sometimes so
what's this podcast this podcast is
about so many things
fitness anabolics self-help psychology
psychedelics anything i want it to be
but mainly i'm going to try to root this
in
trying to better yourself through
fitness and all the related things from
there i'll tell you about my life i want
to hear about your life i want to make
this an interactive community where
everybody can laugh
live
and love
so
as i mentioned before i am very grateful
i'm grateful for joining the fake boy
network i'm grateful to have my
wonderful producer the most handsome
producer on the internet the most
handsome podcast producer let's just
specify i don't know if there's other
producers outside of the podcast world
who are more handsome than casey but
casey garrity internet's most handsome
podcast producer let's give it up
appreciate you
and everybody's favorite intern
christian
yes i'm going to try to incorporate just
you know i'm going to pretend you guys
are i'm not going to pretend you guys
are not in the room anymore i've done it
for too long but i had this realization
of like why am i not talking to you guys
like i do in normal life because i i
love you guys and i want to discuss what
i'm discussing here with you sometimes i
need somebody to bounce some ideas off
of so as i mentioned before a couple
things i was grateful about this week
and just to give you a window into my
life i'm an actor i have auditions
sometimes and sometimes
i'm super psyched about them because i
know i'm going to be right for that
thing potentially and sometimes i'm not
excited at all because i'm not right for
that thing like casey have you ever had
an audition and you know immediately
you're not gonna be selected
yeah particularly with like stunt stuff
my older brother's a stunt man and so
sometimes they'll be like yeah you have
the right look or something but i know
i'm physically incapable of what they're
asking yeah and now do you still go how
do you audition for stone stuff
um so the they'll be like a stunt
coordinator and they'll kind of like
reach out to you and be like hey are you
available these days can you put
yourself on tape this that kind of thing
so it's less formal than like going
through an agent or a manager for
typical acting stuff so it's kind of
just up to the coordinator but you still
got to show the goods precisely yeah you
still got to put yourself on tape and
deuce i assume you're doing some sort of
stunt on tape right
uh no typically they'll just have you
like
uh just to make sure you have the right
look kind of gotcha okay it's assumed
you can do the stunt which in my case is
not yeah i could yeah i could i can
horse back right yeah for sure um
i can do a triple backflip so
in this instance it was for you know i
can't say exactly what the movie is but
it's a horror movie with an iconic
serial killer and they're open to all
ranges of types
but immediately the things they
reference are like jackie earl haley and
little children if you know who that is
um
somebody who looks like you know creepy
chimo a creepy kiddly fiddler on the
roof now
that's not me they're not saying he has
to be like that but like the other
example is like or like bill skarsgard
and it you know i don't really look like
him either i just i have my doubts about
them casting a 240 pound muscular
uh
lead in this horror movie however you
still got to give it your go your
your best shot
and
try to make it as good as possible and
this just happened to be more involved
uh audition that had me like improvise a
story about
killing a childhood pet you know from
the perspective of of the main character
which
even though i don't think i'll get it
just having that monologue actually on
film i think was tough i'm like oh i
kind of like what i came up with you
know patching together little details of
different things that i've had and
making it you know into a
psychopathic pet murder scene but
um
another thing that happened as i was
filming part of it is like
you're supposed to like be filming a
selfie thing that's like this dark
moment where um the guy kills himself
and i thought it'd be really smart to
use this fake gun and then drop the
camera like as i pulled the trigger and
of course the first take it smashes
so i'm like great i have um i'm not
gonna get this audition i broke my phone
over luckily i have insurance but
it's just one of those auditions don't
take it person no but what i'm saying is
sometimes those i shot it in multiple
locations i had you know multiple things
going on because they asked you for this
i asked you for an interview they ask
you for a story they ask you for a clip
that has to be lit a certain way if you
really want to maximize
how you could be seen as that character
and then i send it out and let it go
knowing that i it's a 99.9 chance
generously that i'd get the role however
then you have other stuff
another thing i'm really excited for
where
these things come up and i go i know i'd
be perfect for that
right i know they would be stupid not to
cast me and that usually
has to do with something like if you
need like a tall guy who's like over a
certain weight and muscular and long
hair you know they do have these like we
need a barbarian and he also needs to do
like improv comedy i'm like well there's
three other guys in los angeles who
could do it like me
so you know a low bar a small pool but
it still gives you that confidence uh
and validation that you're like all
right maybe you know sacrificing my look
of any
sort of normalcy as far as size and
appearance go
sometimes that does pay off so i have
another one that i can't say too much
about but if it goes through
you'll be hearing a lot about it and
i'll be very excited to talk to you
about it
i hate to be that guy right now big
things coming man you know what i'm
saying just keep posted right come back
tomorrow and the next day to my
instagram we're doing big things
everybody's doing big things but uh in
this case i just it's cool to like get
attention from a casting director and
then you hear the director wants to see
you because you're like yes i knew i'd
be right for this and they kind of
realized it too so even if nothing
happens from it
it's cool to just get that little bit of
validation
and that goes a long way when you can
behave in a grateful fashion towards
those little moments so
other good news catalytic converter
replaced suck it haters
um
speaking of which i'm going to interject
here with a mark harley meme of the week
this is a new segment i want to start
but somebody makes this adam mentality
world made this i thought it was
fantastic
it shows me
behind the wheel of a prius
surrounded by motorcyclists and the
caption
is haters will say that mark harley is
not in the house angels now that his
catalytic conversion converter was
stolen amazing great job and if you want
people make me into memes every week a
few people really go to photoshop do
this
and they got that cleverness like i said
all my my fans are just so consistently
more funny than my haters if you sense
something like this even if it was more
offensive to me
and mean but it was this like clever and
well done i would post it
still waiting haters
so
that's a side note
to the fact that i got my catalytic
converter replaced and
wanted to touch on something that
happened
yesterday by the time you'll be
listening to this it will have been a
few days but
brendan
pulled his hamstring yesterday
racing chappelle
wanted to use that as an opportunity to
talk about some things both mindset and
just the nuts and bolts of what should
do
when you're injured and how to recover
from that and bulletproof it in the
future so look i've pulled my hamstring
a number of times from sprinting it
usually is in that like final gear of
you're not just going fast you're like
trying to beat somebody you know you're
going much faster than you normally
would i mean it happens to the best of
the best olympic sprinters
can pull a hamstring so so can the
average person trying to beat their
friend
in an ill-advised foot race
you know the crucial thing here is that
brendan has the tough mudder coming up
in what was 10 days from when he injured
it and or so he injured both of his
hamstrings
roughly at the same time which is
equally devastating because
you know just to walk around you have to
you can't like
fully
immobilize that leg and not use it at
all like you could if you just had one
wrong one one torn so
you're gonna shoot your position having
both and it's just obviously more
depressing to pull both
sides of
both muscles on both sides of the body
however
with some rest
with some massage with some healing
peptides i do believe it is possible not
to get back to full speed and actually
sprint again after 10 days but i'm
optimistic about brendan being able to
jog even a long distance even that 10
miles that the uh
what is it like 15k something more
roughly so
the
10 miles it'll be tough it'll be
exhausting who knows maybe i'm being
overly optimistic but i think that he
will be showing up and doing the thick
mudder regardless of this minor setback
and it's also an opportunity for me to
talk about your mindset again i'll
always talk about this when you have an
injury i've made the mistake
many times before of giving it up
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
saying
because i've had this injury i'm not
getting anything else i'm going to go
off my diet
i'm not going to do any other form of
training i'm going to
slack off and not do recovery or rehab
because even that is
you know you find it pointless when
you're more depressed
but if you can just allow yourself to
have that day or that moment
to feel like
okay yeah pout get it out be angry be
disappointed in yourself
you know feel like a dumb ass for doing
something that you know you didn't have
to do it's an unforced error
but then get right back on that horse i
remember i pulled a hamstring right
before senior year of college playing
football like the day before camp
started so i was i worked out all summer
so hard isolated myself worked a job and
was just like working and working out
and then trying to beat my friend in a
series of 100 yard sprints like my
running back friend we're doing like 10
of them and on the fifth one i'm like
i'm gonna beat his ass this time and
like got out to a good start you know um
and pulled up and like you know 30 yards
in with a pulled hamstring that lasted
the whole season because i never let it
heal properly and so that's another
mistake you make is
rushing to get back especially with peer
pressure with other people are you going
to play this week can you do this i'm
like yeah sure i think but you always
have to listen to yourself you can't
push it and if you let it heal properly
it's a there's a much better chance
you'll never have an issue with it again
moving forward so
um
moving forward what do you do
with a hamstring like that we're going
to hit deadlifts harder we're going to
do kettlebell swings we're going to do
heavy hamstring curls we're going to do
nordic drops that's one of the best
movements that you can do for
strengthening hamstrings and preventing
injuries they've studied this in
comparison to hamstring curls guys who
did sets of nordic drops had less
hamstring pulls
i want to personally work my way up to
the point where i can do a nordic drop
which is you anchor your your ankles you
put your
hands either in front of you or behind
you and sort of using your hamstrings
you lower your upper body
you lower your chest to the floor
without anything else touching besides
your knees really hard to do
you can start by dropping into it kind
of like
doing the negative hold the negative as
much as you can and then drop and then
push back up and do it again
so nordic drops one leg are deals it's a
great athletic movement get a full
stretch balance on one leg and lunges in
general i think are good
um oh and the weighted hyper extensions
that keep your
leg outstretched and you can just
generate a lot of force against
um
your hamstrings in a position where it
kind of mimics you know your foot
outstretched striking during a sprint
okay
and i was gonna say one more thing i'm
grateful for
this guy that i met on ig who's a doctor
who was uh
helping me
both figure out my shoulder injury i
have and brendan's hamstring last night
people will reach out to me and like
just offer their expertise and i'm like
goddamn this is so cool social media is
so cool that i can
meet you online and you can be an expert
a doctor and you're like and i you know
i'm retired i just want to help you i
have some time and i'm going to give you
my expertise for free so i think this is
actually somebody who you're going to be
seeing more of lately because that's
such a good conversation and our
interests align in such a way because
not every doctor is into bodybuilding
and anabolics and stuff like that this
guy is so
look out big things coming you know what
i'm saying we got a doctor on the show
god goddamn
crazy comment of the week i'm gonna
start reading some of the best comments
from the comments section
last week as i talked about a guy's
house burnt down we put up the gofundme
forum somebody uh trunk trunks smash
said my house got burned down took one
minute looked at my room and said [ __ ]
it got my dog out ran around looking for
the cats once outside i realized i
forgot my sister
ran back inside and got her out all i
could think was my hispanic parents will
kill me if i don't if i didn't get her
out into the fire i go i like that
that's sort of the voice in his head
like man if i let my sister die my
parents are gonna kill me
not like hey i want my sister to not
burn in a fiery blaze also specifying
hispanic parents as if any other
ethnicity parents would
leave their sister in there
how would your parents feel if you left
giova if you left johnny uh burning in
the house christian
um they would definitely not be happy
you know yeah definitely if gianni left
me then it'd be a different story
there's a little just oh yeah he's
definitely the face okay oh yeah well
i'm glad you got yourself out you know
you got to do what you got to do um
yeah the idea that like well you know my
white parents were like whatever did you
try your best here's a participation
trophy
in the shape of a flame
so
if you keep writing crazy comments like
that and give me fodder i'm going to
read them out because that was goddamn
funny i also want to start a new segment
called liver king meme of the week
because he's just the gift that keeps on
giving i know i use that phrase a lot
but like the liver king has become one
of my favorite internet personalities i
know i call them out uh
for being a fitness charlatan in some
degrees i'm not saying that i disagree
with any of the dietary recommendations
that he
gives out regarding eating animal organs
i'm sure that can be very helpful i'd
love to try it sometime just as an
experiment but the main thing we talk
about is the fact that
he's obviously super enhanced
anabolically and makes no mention of it
while selling you diet and training
programs that implicitly suggests you
can look like me if you train and eat
like me but you're leaving the huge
bordeaux don't you
so
the first one the runner up here is
what are these little characters is that
like anime stuff do you know these the
guys in purple
not sure we can okay
well it's two action figure big action
figure
um like a taller one that's meant to be
a bigger person but it's still very
small when you put it on the table
because he's blocking
some
strands of spaghetti from coming out
the spaghetti is debilitating insecurity
the big guy blocking that from coming
out and hitting the little guy behind
him is tren
and then the little guy behind him that
he's saving from the debilitating
insecurity spaghetti is liver king and
that's funny to me because it's accurate
like he does seem like he was a guy who
like got bullied or picked on and is
overcompensating and saying i'm not
saying that's a bad thing it's just that
one of my favorite things about this guy
is that he's sort of terminally awkward
you know the way he addresses people
it's like hello primals today we're
eating 18 egg yolks and every time that
i work i put my computer outside in the
sun stacked on rogue boxes can't you see
that i have an 80 foot extension cord
going back to the house you know
everything's like
i live in a bed uh that's surrounded by
wi-fi proof 18-inch cement walls so i
can't look at my phone at night you know
and it's like that's really cool like am
i ever gonna go to that length to to
replicate you know what my ancestors
lived like um
speaking of which the winner
is a little four-part comic here
featuring the liver king
he's like discovering these these
scrolls like in water or something like
he's up it's like some crystal cave and
he's like i finally found it after 15
years the scroll of truth
opens it up and it reads our ancient
ancestors didn't have internet and
social media and then in the final frame
he's going yeah throws it away
it's funny because it's true right
your whole message is preach ancestral
living now i get it it's a contradiction
it's it's an impossibility that you
could spread that message effectively if
you didn't use social media but we get
to call them out anyway right
um because obviously in order to make
money off of this philosophy you're
compromising the philosophy to some
degree so i just love pointing out how
money corrupts people that's all i want
to say
okay if this is your first time on the
page
then this will be your first hater of
the week congratulations on experiencing
such a cool segment of the podcast for
the first time now
i'll give you a little background it's
not just about who's the meanest to me
because there are people who say mean
things all the time they just sort of
can kind of get repetitive unclever or
just
too mean-spirited without any humor and
sometimes people do the most devastating
things they don't even mention me by
name but
i know that they're coming after me and
they're coming after me hard and the
sheer
ingenuity
that these people utilize
in hating on me is something that i have
to applaud so here we have
a picture of a goat with a human face
face mask
and i don't know if you guys can see
this but that's my face i don't know
this person
and like could it not be my face sure
but like
i i don't i see more evidence that it is
my face than that it is in my face
specifically note that there's a dark
spot on this
on the lip of the face mask that's on
the goat that matches a dark spot that i
have in the exact same place on my lip
on the lips that are the exact same
shape
below a goatee a mustache on a goatee
that's the exact same length and shape
same skin tone same this same that
so
wally in the house is the tick tock and
instagram account
i guess as this is uh you know some
celebrity goat let's go with that
and
is there a link there yeah let's play
this
this is funny
[Music]
how am i supposed to live life love in
these conditions she's saying how am i
supposed to live laugh love in these
conditions which i think is funny on its
own and i actually posted it without
thinking about it
and then people were sending me like is
that you i'm like wait a second it is me
does this woman know i'm gonna have to
reach out to her and be like
where'd you i
you wanna [ __ ]
because that's that's the vibe i'm
getting here
um but if you did do it on purpose bravo
if you didn't do it on purpose you're
lying and it's obvious to everybody so
just wake up we got a little picture
down there too just to cap it off of me
right of my mouth down there can we make
that bigger i don't know if it does but
yeah
like you'll see see in the upper right
little corner of there and i know it can
actually photoshop it out a little you
can see it but it's like a little dark
mark that i have my lip tell me that's
not my mouth okay
and i'll tell you that you're a liar
so another thing i like to do each week
is introduce my
loyal viewers and the intelligent
creative wonderful people who watch my
show
to other really cool pages either on
instagram or youtube or some combination
of the two
the one i'm going to do this week is a
guy called leo and longevity
mainly i watch his youtube videos he
does have an instagram page um
but i think he just kind of posts the
the thumbnails of the videos that he
posts on youtube
one of the most interesting channels
on the internet to me
the log line of the channel is the
number one channel for biohackers
manipulating biology for performance and
longevity and i think that's kind of an
interesting outgrowth of like you could
be interested in anabolics but you're
also interested in the science of not
just bodybuilding not just being like
how can i get as jacked as humanly
possible and forget about every single
other thing because that is one pursuit
and you still need
an expertise in that area to do that
successfully and not you know kill
yourself as quickly as you might
otherwise just
blasting in godly amounts of gear but
there's also a science to doing it right
increasing your longevity and that kind
of correlates with like if you're
optimizing your hormones you're
optimizing you know your hair growth and
how your skin looks and how you do with
women it kind of opens up this world
into just general not self-help but
self-improvement and looking for hacks
that you can
implement to make everything about your
life better that's how i would describe
this page okay
i think it's going to suffice to say
that
i can share what this page is about with
you just by reading some of the recent
titles on the videos that he posts
i've watched some of these i've never
watched a leon longevity video and felt
like nah that wasn't worth it or i
didn't learn something he brings the
receipts he brings the facts he brings
the studies and the topics are just like
all over the place but somehow they're
they always like i understand where that
came from and it's mainly just something
that he's curious about let's look at
some of these titles how to protect your
brain from punches
why you can't call people the r word
you can't call people republicans uh
more neck more sex
fingers and sexual orientation that was
one i watched recently where like you
can look at
uh studies of people like if this finger
is longer than that one it means it
predicts something about your sexual
orientation to both men and women that
you know
um sorry this this your your
ring finger to your index finger
and
its association with androgen exposure
in the womb has all sorts of these
interesting predictors later in life
a country so dirty its people are short
it's a video about india that's not
racist that's just me telling you he did
a video on it
and also he's from the middle east so
how can he be racist against anybody
else
redheads in bed
that just seems like it's a porno title
but i listened to the video and watched
it and i thought it was really
interesting actually
because it asks a question it's like you
kind of i like things too like malcolm
gladwell people take this stereotype
idea and then see if there's any truth
to it you know like are asians really
good at math and malcolm gladwell took
that thing and go could there be a
reason for that and examine their
language and it's like oh yeah if you
count to 20 in chinese
every little word is shortest if you're
a kid maybe you have an easier time
counting to 20 and then you have this
built-in advantage over the course of
decades and
you know maybe
is there a behavioral difference in
redheads that makes them more crazy in
bed i don't know i mean there is some
speculation and evidence for that but i
don't know i'm not saying that obviously
leo's just saying that ted bundy was
right about porn there's another video a
biohacker's guide to quitting smoking
how to deal with a narcissist so if
you're ever talking to me and want a
guide for that
you can just watch that video
this made my this made your penis
smaller i almost said my but like
obviously your penis got smaller not
mine um and my penis got bigger in
comparison to yours as well
meth jaw how to become more attractive
with facial hair okay leo you know i
feel like you're just rubbing it in at
this point because i can't grow a beard
and i feel like that's a shot at me as
far as like
what if you can't grow a beard and you
want to get more attracted so i'm just
i'm just [ __ ] no cool
i get it dude um
edit this whole segment out
all righty ready ready ready ready
righty we got another hella chef harley
for you
if you're new to the page again
i'm gonna try to bring you recipes that
i've actually used in my real life and
when that runs out i'll use other
recipes that i haven't used or recipes
from you guys that you can send in that
i can try and actually eat on the show
but for now it's just stuff that i've
tried that i like that are like
like leo and his bio hacking these are
my diet hacks and just things that
i have implemented to to scratch the
itch of something i really like
while maintaining a caloric deficit by
eating high volume foods that are high
in protein
and
you know
low to moderate carbs and fat
that also taste really good and scratch
that itch of something that you really
want but it's
just way healthier you know both
calorically and
on a micronutrient level so
this is going to be the chocolate
protein lava cake there's a bunch of
recipes all over the internet for this
specific uh little snack
greg ducettes is the first one that i
used and tried and i you know he's if
you know him he's always pitching his
cookbook but anything i've tried from
gregory said's cookbook has been
phenomenal so
this is another example of that but if
you wanted a different recipe and you
just want to get something random off
the internet there's plenty of
variations on this what you're going to
need
is a cup of egg whites
first of all big mixing bowl right cup
of egg whites one half cup water
40 grams of cocoa powder
three packets of the sweetener of your
choice like i like splenda but you could
do stevia or whatever you want one
teaspoon xanthan gum i think that was
the only thing i had to go out and get
that's like maybe not going to be in
your pantry
but it's a thickener
five scoops of protein powder or 190
grams of protein powder if you want to
weigh it out precisely because i know it
can kind of be tough to get an exact
same scoop every single time
but
the one i use the flavor is p you know
i'm a big fan of pe science the cake pop
for the protein pancakes and then also
um the chocolate frosted cupcake from my
regular shakes and for this recipe the
chocolate
peanut butter cup
is phenomenal and the peanut butter is
not overwhelming so it still tastes like
a chocolate lava cake and the peanut
butter just adds a little something
satiating um to the mix makes it a
little bit richer and it's just the
perfect flavor for this recipe so
you mix all that up until it feels like
cake batter okay
um
and i believe there's five servings in
that actually
pour each one you can have this big bowl
of batter pour
into a medium-sized bowl
one-fifth of the batter you put it in
the microwave for 35 seconds and it
comes out fluffy
around the rim
like you know a cake
and then in the middle it's nice and
gooey
remind you of something get your mind
out of the gutter i'm talking about
regular lava cake
god you're sick
anyway
148 calories per serving 2.8 grams of
fat 23.6 grams of protein 1 gram sugar 4
grams fiber and it tastes like cake if
you're not shoving garbage down your
throat all day this might actually taste
good crazy to think but
it's a legit dessert it's something i've
had a number of times and like look
forward to it it was satisfying i'm like
oh i feel like i ate a dessert right so
if you're somebody who's like i would i
want to lose more weight but i just had
this sweet tooth
use a hack like this all right
turn that sweet tooth into a splendid
tooth
can we move on are you guys chef'd up
enough
god damn how many recipes do i have to
give you oh mark we want more oh my god
i'm still hungry bless us with your vast
knowledge of diet and nutrition okay
dude chill out
it's like god can i take drugs anymore
speaking of which
i thought the hella psychedelic
portion of the podcast went well last
time i talked about my experience a
little bit and just
micro dosing mushrooms with from a
rhonda patrick video where there seems
to be some really interesting
recent insights into how that could
potentially
cure or at least mitigate depression
for at least six months is when they
studied it really interesting stuff and
i invited you guys to to comment below
wanted to read a couple of the comments
just because i've had so many positive
experiences and like i love hearing from
other people like yeah yeah because i
used to be scared of lsd used to be
scared of psychedelics and didn't
realize you can really manage it you
know i'll have people who get blackout
drunk being like but i never do lsd i'm
like huh like
it's so much safer there's even a really
interesting video one time have you ever
seen this casey where like
there's this guy who's like i'm gonna i
don't know why you would it wasn't like
it was crazy viral but it was super
interesting and maybe you've experienced
this
the guy was like i'm gonna take five
shots and then and on one day and take
five uh tabs of acid on another day and
film myself doing things like juggling
or like catching balls or like
coordinated you know like hitting a
baseball
i'm using a lot of baseball examples
here but what i'm saying is it would be
anything that would indicate a general
coordination athleticism and kind of
like you know could you drive a car i
don't like not to where he's actually
going oh i crashed her on lsd and didn't
but
a battery of tests let's say it was
remarkable
how much more coordinated he was on lsd
like you're just dropping you're drunk
it's like like you can't stand up you
can't you know there's a reason you do
the drunk test you really can't pass a
certain blood alcohol level you can't do
it on lsd you would never have known
and this is five tabs deep like you were
tripping balls you know like you were
seeing full-on psychedelic visuals
i don't know if you're like i've never
like hallucinated something that i
thought was there like i always know
what's but it's like there is an overlay
of like you know bright saturated colors
and shapes and this whole firework
display going on at that level of lsd um
but you can apparently still you know if
you really
wanted to you can
access your your full
uh intellectual capacity and
coordination and athleticism so
rant over i'm going to read this
comment here best trip ever lsd at
bonnaroo in like 05 i think it was a
saturday and the weather was hot but no
one cared good
we were all a bunch of half naked kids
with our parents money trying to be the
biggest hippie we could i like this
guy's honesty
you had to throw it you know because
somebody says the festival is so cool
i'm like
yeah you're leaving out the part where
like somebody else is financing this um
it was a saturday the weather was hot no
one cared okay i read that some guys
walk up
while we were waiting for a band to
start with liquid liquid acid and drop
it on me and my girlfriend's tongue we
tripped so hard for about 10 to 12 hours
one cool thing about lsd is that it does
the high lasts longer than almost any
drug it's like stable
as a high for 10 to 12 hours it's crazy
it was an amazing experience we both
just fully immersed ourselves in the
music people and each other we ended up
seeing jack johnson ben harper robert
randolph the allman brothers and
widespread panic in one day we made our
way to the comedy tent that night i
think it was the same day we saw mitch
hedberg but could have been someone else
that exact day we laughed on that lsd
literally all day long i've had many
similar experiences where it's like my
face hurts oh because i was laughing the
entire day three days of pure enjoyment
but that lsd trip changed our lives in a
good way we even set a breakup date and
we held true to it which is nuts but
cool it made me it made us understand
ourselves and we could be totally honest
with each other and ourselves about our
plans for our lives we were young
nothing else i found does that shrooms
are close though i agree i also prefer
lsd to shrimps and
i'm sticking on that little sentence
right there where he goes we set a
breakup date it's like that's the kind
of radical honesty i'm not saying this
can happen to everybody but you have
these moments where you're like
i can let go because if you're letting
go of ego and that's dissolving to a
degree
what is so correlated with ego is things
like jealousy and fear and all that
stuff so if you can let jealousy and
fear go yeah you could probably have an
honest conversation about your breakup
one more is after some from my buddy
maddie moldovan
after some crazy events took mushrooms
in the forest in whistler bc changed my
life forever we all have
a duty to hold ourselves accountable
everything we need is inside no one is
coming to save us accountability so i
guess that's the message that you took
away from this but i'm not surprised
sometimes you kind of emerge from these
experiences with themes you know like
accountability i mean you know you
understand it just clicks in like damn
yes and i like that idea that like no
one's coming to save you maybe somebody
will but you cannot expect
that
and especially when we're looking at
foundational things for our well-being
like the gym nobody's coming to get you
to pick you up to drive it to the gym
maybe i will someday but
you know
nobody's coming for me and it's a good
attitude to have that
you know
hold yourself accountable first and good
things will happen i also wanted to
share one quick experience i took four
tabs one time that i like found in my
like
i've had a lot of ill-advised drug
experience where i'm just like oh like i
found four tabs in you know this
suitcase from a trip that you know went
on two years ago and
acid does degrade so maybe it wasn't
like a full like four tabs because it
does degrade in sunlight over time if
you have it out in the air but i just
popped him and was like alone in my
mom's room
in my mom's house in my own room um
but
this is like a number of years ago it's
like 2015 or something like that and i
dislike it was at night and i sort of
for the first few hours i was like just
laying in bed
and like
working through like my own trauma about
my dad's death is what it felt like like
i was just thinking about him and like
processing memories and kind of like
coming to terms with it
just inside my head for several hours
but it was like a positive it wasn't
like a nightmare like no i can't get out
of my head it was like i'm thinking
about the good and the bad and you know
you're having all this wide range of
emotions
that's not so much notable as what
happened when i got up and went
downstairs and it's like three in the
morning and nobody's up and i'm like i
kind of just you know was mentally
exhausted from that thought
process that i'd been going through the
last few hours and i wanted to put on
the tv what was on the tv was this doc
that i was like later i'm like did i
watch that was i just imagining that on
lsd but the craziest kind of takeaway
from this thing was
in russia there's this uh
fox domestication program are you aware
of this okay um
like because people you can buy fox now
they're expensive but like basically
they in you know there's an abundance of
foxes in russia
they would catch them and put them in um
these crates and sort of like label them
like um either hostile neutral or
friendly right and they would take like
only the neutral and friendly or maybe
even just the friendly ones and like
sort of do like this rapid
um you know genetic selection
like accelerate the process of
domesticating foxes in a few decades it
started in the 60s and now it's complete
where they have this like domesticated
fox breed and so over time you just keep
selecting for like friendly traits so
you get these friendly fog but like you
know probably two-thirds of foxes are
either neutral or like will bite you
when you open a door right just to begin
with
but if you breed all the
friendly ones they're going to be
friendly to humans
very very reliably
the interesting takeaway from that is
each successive generation that was bred
for friendly traits
you could see these uh phenotypic
markers so their physical appearance
changed
um as they selected for behavioral
genes
and they started to look more like
domesticated dogs oh
my god i was like what
like the same the same path physically
that wolves took to look more like dogs
like their ears started to flop over
their snouts became like every like if
you look at a you know modern dog that's
not you know i'm talking about like a
little tiny [ __ ] chihuahua but like
you know look at a golden retriever
versus a wolf
those
like a domesticated fox is three of
those steps toward you know what the
golden retriever became that was his
mind blowing to me like holy [ __ ] you
know
it'll always stay with me maybe you're
like okay and what's the rest of the
story nothing you can buy a fox if you
want to if you have 10 000 bucks and you
want a domesticated fox it's gonna have
little floppy ears just like your pet
doggy
that sounds like a sick documentary that
you definitely imagined on drugs
i know right
it was all in my head uh
everybody's dead i'm dead
um
all right in the hella personality
portion of the podcast we're going to
finish up here
so
a lot of people brought in also
like they took the test i had you guys
take the myers-briggs at
16personalities.com i told you about
myself
here's one thing i wanted to look at
a lot of people came up with infj type
and they put it in the comments now
infjs are supposed to be one percent of
the population i'm not saying you guys
are liars sometimes you do get
inaccurate results but
it's a phenomenon where maybe there's
something about
you know different personality types i
always feel like three you know three
types are mainly drawn to me and i'm not
going to tell you those right now but
like you are going to experience if you
went and had your friends took it you
would see like
it probably skews towards two to three
main types of people who you're gonna
naturally end up being friends with so
it doesn't surprise me that one that's
supposed to be only one percent of the
population is disproportionately
represented in my comments because maybe
you're more interested in ideas like
this or the way that i communicate or
whatever but i saw like three people
post infj
which shouldn't happen ever but i'm
gonna read that [ __ ] out loud all right
i'm gonna click this bad boy it's the
advocate an advocate of somebody with
introverted
intuitive feeling and judging
personality traits they tend to approach
life with deep thoughtfulness and
imagination their inner vision personal
values and a quiet principled version of
humanism guide them in all things
advocates are the rarest to personality
types of all still advocates believe
advocates leave their mark on the world
they have a deep sense of idealism and
integrity and by the way all nf types
like enfps infps enfjs infjs are
idealists
they see the best in the world and work
towards something that many other people
would consider impractical you know like
solving world hunger or something like
that many people be like yeah that's
never going to happen
but nf types tend to work towards those
really big idealistic goals deep sense
of idealism and integrity but they
aren't idle dreamers they take concrete
steps to realize their goals and making
a lasting impact advocates unique
combination of personality traits make
them complex and quite versatile for
example advocates can speak with great
passion and conviction especially when
standing up for their ideals at other
times however they may choose to be
soft-spoken and understated preferring
to keep the peace rather than challenge
others
very true they stand up for what's right
helped create a world where others
do the right thing as well i'm going to
jump to
you can read more at sixteen
on
this specific archetype
but i was going to tell you some famous
ones because that's always fun right
someday i'll come back to entps and the
famous entps
but
fictional and real famous infjs include
martin luther king
mother teresa
but if you haven't read christopher
hitchens book on her please do that
because people sort of use her that that
name as a
a stand-in for best person ever however
she does sort of represent the dark side
of an infj
which i'll get to in a second because if
you take some of these qualities to an
extreme you can become hyper idealistic
it can interfere with other people's
well-being if you take if you have
control and power and take things to an
extreme nelson mandela lady gaga nicole
kidman
khaleesi
and let's not forget the most famous
infj of all hitler
another one where you go i might have
taken things
as far as personality traits you know
these people are creative they're
organized but it maybe they get a little
bit crazy
khaleesi when i was watching game of
thrones spoiler alert
i like to predict like for tyson
lannister as an entp right
um for example so i'd like to play the
game of like
you never know because like they come
with some guide but you can see what
other people say on the internet so i
like to type people as i'm watching
shows that are really well written like
game of thrones
is an infj she was always
convicted based on her beliefs and her
morals and doing the right thing she
made all these really like rogue
decisions you know to like free these
warriors when everybody's advising her
against it and give people freedom and
sort of you know treat them egalitarian
but then the
that righteousness went to her head and
it became very destructive right in a
similar fashion we see something like
with hitler where it's like this extreme
sort of righteousness that allows
uh you to suspend your empathy for the
suffering of others even though you
might have started out in an attempt to
you know at least claiming like i'm
going to better the people and then you
end up destroying the people
um
not to end on those two terrible
examples but
i think infjs are super fascinating
super smart some of my best and most
interesting friends and another
difference between i'm an
n and their ends but there's two
different kinds of ends every trait is
like
like n and s you can be
have introverted intuition or
extroverted intuition i have extroverted
intuition i like creating connections in
the outside world
and an infj uses intuition in a slightly
different way where they sort of like
get answers from this mysterious web
inside their head often they'll get
answers to things like i don't know how
i got there but it's right and i know it
and
um you know there's like an oracle
quality to it
and i sort of have a i guessed right
quality to me
i don't know what i'm talking about but
maybe
all right let's end it off with a
this is why we can't have nice gyms okay
click this little link here
and the reason we can't have nice gyms
listen to this guy
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you dog
here's the thing you're letting the
jesus
he's letting the dog into the gym
and then he's getting mad when the dog
dogs all right we can't be doing that
and this is why we can't have nice gyms
because you want the dog around but you
don't want the dog to be a dog so just
chill dog
if you're going to have the dog in he's
going to do dog things and he's going to
squat he's going to want to do
everything
that you're doing because dog is man's
best friend
definitely doesn't deserve the best dad
ever shirt i know it's like you know hey
take that shirt off buddy
you can you are not the best doggo dada
you just said [ __ ] you to the cutest dog
i've ever seen exactly so
i also wanted to play this because um
friend of the show bradley martin
um
brad if you're watching this i'm still
waiting on that raw gear contract if you
don't mind sending that over um you know
i thought like
you know i'm 22 i'm ripe for the
sponsorship i think it'd be perfect so
um you know you said maybe and i feel
like you were playing hard to get but if
you just like just just be honest man i
know you want me on the team so to send
over that contract um i was over
bradley's house shooting a sketch with
isaiah and some other people
and they had his dog in a pen
and the dog [ __ ] all over the place and
pissed oh stinky gigantic diary but can
you blame the dog right they're like oh
my god the dog's showing like oh the dog
[ __ ] locked up in a pen with no you know
litter box or thing to cover the floor
like of course it is you know put me in
a jail cell for a day or whatever like
with no toilet i'm not gonna make um
could you let me out so i can pee and
the toilet dogs are gonna [ __ ] and piss
wherever they can so
that's not the story the story is i look
at that and go it's disgusting of course
it was super stinky and gross but i'm
like i love animals and i consider it
sort of my penance
when i'm cleaning up the cat [ __ ] out of
the box you know from four different
cats
i'm going this is the price i pay one of
the you know many prices obviously
you're buying
food and paying for vet bills and stuff
like that
but this is like the humbling experience
that i want talk about gratitude
you have to be humbled in order
to express gratitude and cleaning up
animal [ __ ] is one of the best ways to
humble yourself so
i used a whole roll of paper towels
cleaned up that giant pile of diarrhea
wiped it down
and i guess brad wasn't there word got
around to him he thanked me in the dms
and uh we had a little moment at zoo
culture the other day where i just said
i said the same thing here i said you
know this is like the price for me
to love animal i'm an animal lover and i
will pay that price
i will clean up that [ __ ]
as eminem once said i shoveled [ __ ] on
my life and now i'm dumping it on them
who am i dumping it on the people who
don't like animals okay oh i'm sorry
animal haters
poo poo on your dome
well i guess that's it huh
i guess that was the best episode of the
week of january 24th
2022. that's not just me saying it
that's you guys going online voting over
12 million times for this episode of the
podcast which hasn't even been released
yet
but just the word on the street was so
strong that you came through
and you said
mark
i just have this feeling i have this
vibe i have this confidence that the
unreleased episode is going to be so
good that i'm going to go
to best podcast episodes of the week dot
com and vote for haters will say episode
18.
thank you for watching
like comment subscribe put your type
down there put your psychedelic
experience down there put any questions
you have for me because there's nothing
i love more in life than pretending to
know what i'm talking about to answer
your questions
until we meet again tune back in next
week and guess what oh
oh yeah
there might be another little button
taking oh oopsies oh i'm sorry
did my did my shirt come off right at
the
end of the show
you